these are some of the world's most
iconic typefaces you've probably seen
them on classic ads newspapers posters
even memes these typefaces were
carefully crafted every curve considered
the legibility of their design paramount
oh wait I forgot one it's a little
different than the others this one was
likely designed on graph paper converted
into binary code in skin 60 times a
second on to a cathode ray screen you
probably recognize it when it says this
this font had a big responsibility it
needed to balance legibility and
creativity too but it had to do it while
taking off his little computer memory as
possible that's type designer Toshi a
Magary
and that's the font for the arcade game
time pilot 84 one of the mini arcade
fonts he catalogued analyzed and
reviewed for his book arcade game
typography the book contains around 240
fonts and most of them were designed
within this 8x8 grid why does heat by 8
grid
well let's rewind to the Golden Age of
arcade games well they come as if from
outer space in a variety of weird
geysers defender pac-man asteroids it
was space invaders now all different
forms of the game are storming the
market inside these machines are
literally hundreds of circuits and
computer chips a city of electronic
gadgetry and technology here's the
manual for sprint to an 8-bit racing
game released in 1976 right as arcade
games were taking over it explains a lot
about why early video games looked the
way they did the TV monitor display is
divided into a 32 by 28 tile grid each
tile represents one byte of data that's
8 bits if you zoom in more you'll see
the 8-bit tile is divided into its own
8x8 grid where each cell can be turned
on
off the more cells that are turned on
the more computer processing power
required which was super limited back
then the arcade games scanned this
information line by line all the way
down the screen with an electron beam
before it restarted the next frame this
is what it looked like slowed down by
today's standards these tiles would be a
type constraint but developers managed
to make racecars aliens spaceships and
robots these games look the way they did
because they were exercised as an
efficiency and nothing illustrates that
precarious balance of conserving
computer memory more than the letters
and numbers that guided players through
the game sprint twos set of characters
are sort of like the arcade fonts
earliest fossils and they can be traced
back to another game from 1976 these
characters like most arcade fonts or
mono spaced as the name suggests the
same width and because every tile on the
screen is locked together that 8x8 grid
also has to account for the gap between
characters the quiz show character set
stands out first and foremost because of
its proportions because with those rules
I would probably draw 1/8 like this but
the designers of this font also
attempted to follow the calligraphy
tradition of typography ok this is the
quiz show 8 that stresses also how they
differentiated the zero from the O so
the quiz font was designed in the US and
variations of it showed up in a lot of
Atari games but it didn't truly travel
the globe until it jumped over to game
developers in Japan often weren't
familiar with the Latin alphabet
making their own games they just useless
I thought increase your house
there's Japanese developers still
couldn't resist putting their own spin
on it by adding and subtracting a few
pixels here and there you might
recognize this modified W and Y from the
hit game and Galaxian these typeface
variations also had their weird quirks
especially when lowercase letters
entered the picture the biggest
challenge was figuring out exactly what
lowercase letters were supposed to look
like case in point the lowercase
characters for the Japanese made game
rock and rope-tow she found them saved
within the code of the game but they
weren't actually used probably for the
best
the a C and E are giant compared to the
B and the D and some of the letters are
in cursive would you say that it's
harder to make lowercase letters yes
Lucas needs more space because of the
parts assemblies and v centers you also
see lowercase G can be pushed up quite a
bit I think overall quality is probably
vesting model madness that was released
by Atari in 1984 this has an ro that's
move rounded at at all so because it was
also done by Atari it makes me wonder if
the original this extra corner was a
mistake or not with incremental
advancements in technology and a lot of
ingenuity arcade game designers fit more
in more detail into this little 8x8 grid
they added more colors outlines and
shadows the fonts got bolder and more
adventurous there were some completely
illegible designs too sometimes this
damned if you do damned if you don't
situation if you put a pixel that looks
terrible by few tone
it's worse do you have a favorite that
you always sort of like call back to my
go-to favorites is skybox it's based on
the copperplate script genre so yes Fox
has one of the most beautiful script
phases its use of razor amazing
by using rates trying to express the
thickness middle one pixel this
shouldn't be possible the entire set of
letters the most fun part for me is the
gap between the game content and the
typeface basically a spaceship takes aim
at women in bikinis that are writing
mythical creatures one of the most
beautiful shows up in coins inacceptable
James notley's by the end of the arcades
rain these pixelated typefaces came in
all shapes and sizes but this one stood
the test of time showing up in hundreds
of games including pac-man Donkey Kong
and legends of Zelda being confined to
the small grid started as a technical
challenge but quickly became an
impressive exercise and creativity
that's why this font deserves to be
ranked among some of the greats in this
if you're one of our many viewers who
watches our box videos over Wi-Fi then
you might be interested to hear about
our sponsor ting Mobile ting is a
cellular service provider that only
charges you for the data you use instead
of a flat monthly bill so if you use
less data you pay for less that means if
you're the type of person who's almost
always connected to Wi-Fi teen could
earn you serious savings like your phone
bill could be as much as twenty three
dollars a month serious plus you can
bring any phone to ting and there's no
contracts or commitments interested
tracking mobile with a $25 service
credit at Vox teen.com ting mobile
doesn't directly impact our editorial
but their support makes videos like this
possible so go check them out